you mentioned the elephant and the the
monkey riding the elephant
and uh
consciousness is the monkey
and there's some prodding that the
monkey gets to do and sometimes the
elephant listens
i heard you got
into some content maybe you can correct
me but i heard you got into some
contentious free will discussions
uh is this with sam harris or something
like that
not that i know of
some people on clubhouse told me you
made a a bunch of uh um
big debate points about free will well
let me just then ask you where where
in terms of the monkey and the elephant
uh do you think we land in terms of the
illusion of free will how much control
does the monkey have
we have to think about what the um
free will is in the first place
we are not the machine we are not the
thing that is making the decisions we
are a model of that decision-making
process
and
there is a difference between
making your own decisions and predicting
your own decisions yes and that
difference is the first person
perspective
and what
basically makes decision-making um and
the conditions of free will distinct
from just automatically doing the best
thing is
that uh we often don't know what the
best thing is we make decisions under
uncertainty we make informed bets using
a betting algorithm that we don't yet
understand because we haven't reverse
engineered our own mind sufficiently we
don't know the expected rewards we don't
know the mechanism by which we estimate
the rewards and so on but there is an
algorithm we observe ourselves
performing where we see that
we made facts and factors and the future
and then
some kind of possibility some motive
gets raised to an intention and that's
informed bad that the system is making
and that making of the open bet the
representation of that is what we call
free will
and it seems to be paradoxical because
we think that's the crucial thing is
about it that it's somehow
indeterministic
and yet if it wasn't deterministic it
would be random
and of course it cannot be random
because it was if it was random if just
dice were being thrown in the universe
randomly forces you to do things it
would be meaningless so the important
part of the decisions is always the
deterministic stuff
but it appears to be indeterministic to
you because it's unpredictable because
if it was predictable you wouldn't
experience it as a free will decision
right you would experience it as just
doing the necessary right thing
and you see this continuum between the
free will and the execution of automatic
behavior when you are observing other
people so for instance when you are
observing your own children
if you don't understand them you will
use this agent model where you have a
agent with a setpoint generator and the
agent is doing the best it can to
minimize the difference to the set point
and it might be confused and
sometimes impulsive or whatever but it's
acting on its own free will
and when you understand what happens in
the mind of the child you see that it's
automatic and you can out model the
child you can build things around the
child that will lead the child to making
exactly the decision that you're
predicting
and in under these circumstances like
when you are a stage magician or
somebody who is dealing uh with people
that this you sell a car to and you
completely understand the psychology and
the impulses and the space of thoughts
that this individual can have at that
moment under these circumstances it
makes no sense to attribute free will
because it's no longer decision making
under uncertainty you are already
certain for them there is uncertainty
but you already know what they're doing
but what about for you
so
is this akin to like
systems like cellular automata
where it's
deterministic
but when you
squint your eyes a little bit
it starts look like there's agents
making decisions at the higher so
when you zoom out and look at the
entities that
are composed by the individual cells
even though the there's uh underlying
simple rules that
uh make the system evolve in
deterministic ways it looks like there's
organisms making decisions is that
where the illusion of free will emerges
that jump and scale
it's a particular type of model but this
jump in scale is crucial the jumping
scale happens whenever you have too many
parts to count and you cannot make a
model at that level and you try to find
some higher level regularity
and the higher level regularity is a
pattern that you project into the world
to make sense of it and agency is one of
these patterns right you have all these
cells that interact with each other and
the cells in our body are set up in such
a way that they benefit if their
behavior is coherent
which means that they act as if they
were serving a common goal
and which that means that they will
evolve regulation mechanisms that act as
if they were serving a common goal and
now you can make sense of these all
these cells by projecting the common
goal into them right so for you then
free will is an illusion
no it's a model and it's a construct
it's basically a model that the system
is making of its own behavior and it's
the best model that it can come up with
under the circumstances and it can get
replaced by a different model which is
automatic behavior when you fully
understand the mechanism under which you
are acting yeah but the another word for
model is what story
so it's the story you're telling i mean
you actually have control is there such
a thing as a you
and is there such a thing as you have in
control
it's like are you
manifesting
your
evolution as a entity in some sense the
you is the model of the system that is
in control it's a story that the system
tells itself about somebody who is in
control
yeah and the contents of that model are
being used to inform the behavior of the
system
okay so the system is completely
mechanical and the system creates that
story like a loom
and then it uses the contents of that
story to inform its actions and writes
the results of that actions into the
story so how's that not an illusion
the story is written
then
or
or rather we're not the writers of the
story
yes but we always knew that
no we we don't know that when did we
know that i think that's mostly a
confusion about concepts the uh
conceptual illusion in our culture comes
from the idea that we live in physical
reality
and that we experience physical reality
and that we have ideas about it
and then you have this dual list
interpretation where you have
two substances uh res extensor the world
that you can touch and that is made of
extended things and res cognitions which
is the world of ideas
and in fact both of them are mental
representations
one is the representations of the world
as a game engine that your mind
generates to make sense of the
perceptual data and the other ones the
world yes that's what we perceive as the
physical world but we already know that
the physical world is nothing like that
right quantum mechanics is very
different from what you and me perceive
as the world the world that you me
perceive is a game engine yeah and there
are no colors and sounds in the physical
world they only exist in the game engine
generated by your brain and then you
have ideas that are not cannot be mapped
onto extended regions right so the
objects that have a spatial extension in
the game engine are res extensor and the
objects that don't have a physical
extension in the game
engine are ideas
and they both interact in our mind to
produce models of the world yep but
you know when you play video games
i understand that what's actually
happening is zeros and ones inside of uh
inside of a computer instead of a cpu
and a gpu
but you're still seeing
like uh the rendering of that
and you're still making decisions
whether to shoot to turn left or to turn
right if you're playing a shooter or
every time i start thinking about skyrim
and elder scrolls and walking around in
beautiful nature and swinging a sword
but
it feels like you're making decisions
inside that video game so even though
you don't have direct access
uh in terms of perception to the the
bits to the zeros and ones it still
feels like you're making decisions and
your decisions are actually
feels like they're being applied
all the way down to the zeros and ones
yeah so it feels like you have control
even though you don't direct
access to reality so there is basically
a special character in the video game
that is being created by the video game
engine yeah and this character is
serving the aesthetics of the video game
and that is you
yes but i feel like i have control
inside the video game
like all those like 12 year olds that
kick my ass on the internet
so for when you play the video game it
doesn't really matter that they're zeros
and once right you don't care about the
vids of the bus you don't care about the
nature of the cpu that it runs on what
you care about are the properties of the
game that you're playing and you hope
that the cpu is good enough
yes and a similar thing happens when we
interact with physics the world that you
and me are in is not the physical world
the world that you and me are in is a
dream world
how close is it to the real world though
we know that it's not very close but we
know that the dynamics of the dream
world match the dynamics of the physical
world to a certain degree of resolution
right the causal structure of the
dreamboat is different
so you see
waves crashing on your feet right but
there are no waves in the ocean there's
only water molecules that have tangents
uh between the molecules that are uh
the result of electrons in the molecules
interacting with each other aren't they
like very consistent we're just seeing a
very uh crude approximation isn't
our dream world very consistent like to
the point of being mapped directly
one-to-one to the actual physical world
as opposed to
us being completely tricked this is like
where you have like that it's not a
trick that's that's my point it's not an
illusion it's a form of data compression
yeah it's an attempt to deal with the
dynamics of too many parts to count at
the level at which we're entangled with
the best model that you can find yeah so
we can act in that dream world and our
actions have impact in the in the real
world in the physical world yes to which
we don't have access yes but it's
basically like
accepting the fact that the software
that we live in the dream that you live
in is generated by something outside of
this world that you and me are in so is
the software deterministic and do we not
have any control
do we have
so free will
is uh
having a conscious being
the free will is the monkey being able
to steer the elephant
no
it's slightly different
basically in the same way as you are
modeling the water molecules in the
ocean that engulf your feet when you are
walking on the beach as waves and there
are no waves but only the atoms on more
complicated stuff underneath the atoms
and so on and you know that right
you would accept yes there is a certain
abstraction that happens here it's a
simplification of what happens in the
simplification that is designed in such
a way that your brain can deal with it
temporarily and spatially in terms of
resources and tuned for the predictive
value so you can predict with some
accuracy whether your feet are going to
get wet or not but it's a really good
approach it's a really good interface
and approximation yes it's like equals
mg squared is a good
equations are good approximations for or
they're much better approximation
so
to me waves is a really nice
approximation of what's all the
complexity that's happening underneath
basically it's a machine learning model
that is constantly tuned to minimize
surprises so it basically tries to
predict as well as it can what you're
going to perceive next are we talking
about
which is the machine learning our
perception system or the dream world
the machine world dreamworld is the
result of the machine learning process
of the perceptual system that's doing
the compression yes and uh the model of
you as an agent is
not a different type of model or it's a
different type but not uh not different
as in its model like nature from the
model of the ocean right some things are
oceans some things are agents
and uh one of these agents is using your
own control model the output of your
model the things that you perceive
yourself as doing
and that is you
what about
the fact that it's like when you're
standing
um and with the water on your feet and
you're looking out
into the vast
like open water of the ocean and then
there's a beautiful sunset
and it well the fact that it's beautiful
and then maybe you have like friends or
a loved one with you and like you feel
love what is that as the dream world or
what is that yes it's all uh happening
inside of the dream okay
but see the word dream makes it seem
like it's not real
yeah of course it's not real
the physical universe is real but the
physical universe is incomprehensible
and it doesn't have any feeling of
realness the feeling of realness that
you experience gets attached to certain
representations where your brain
assesses this is the best model of
reality that i have so the only thing
that's real to you is the thing that's
happening at the very
base of reality like
yeah for something to be real it needs
to be implemented
so uh the model that you have of reality
is a real in as far as it is a model
right it's an appropriate description of
the world to say that there are models
that are being experienced
but
the world that you experience is not
necessarily implemented
you